she's still handy with a bat the
flamboyant and wickedly funny Harley
Quinn played by Margot Robbie is making
her way to a theater near you
she stood out in Suicide Squad is a
smart strong and sassy woman who always
did whatever she felt was best for
herself and others in any given moment
now free from a relationship with the
Joker Harley takes to action in
birds-of-prey when she learns that an
infamous crime lord is targeting a naive
young girl and teams up with an unlikely
trio of women who are equally determined
to take the villain down here's
everything you need to know before you
go Harley Quinn most recently appeared
in Suicide Squad as Harleen Quinzel a
psychiatrist who is lured to the dark
side by the villainous Joker
she lost her sanity after months of
torture by Joker becoming enslaved to
his evil and believing herself to be in
love with him she is forced into service
as part of the so-called Suicide Squad
and performs viciously as expected after
the successful completion of the mission
she and other surviving squad members
were returned to prison where Harley
received an unexpected visit from a
former enemy so who exactly are the
birds of prey the dynamic team known as
birds of prey were inspired by DC Comics
and include the notorious Harley Quinn
wary mafia princess Huntress played by
Mary Elizabeth Winstead savage songbird
black canary played by jurnee smollett
Belle and sage cop Renee Montoya played
by Rosie Perez and while they come from
different backgrounds they are
ultimately united by their need to
defeat a common rival also starring
alongside these leading ladies is
romance Iona's aka the Black Mask a
vengeful villain played by Ewan McGregor
who rules Gotham at least in his own
mind and Chris Messina stars as Victor
says his primary accomplice who will
pretty much execute whatever his boss
commands the film takes place after
Roman targets young Cassandra Cass Kane
played by Ella Jay Bosco her
disappearance prompts a frantic search
turning the entire city upside down and
while the birds of prey may seem
unlikely heroes they're the only ones
who
brave and courageous enough to find her
and defeat Roman you know I've never
worked on something where every position
of power was led by a woman in one way
or another and it was really exciting
and invigorating and just fun like it
there was no there was nothing
threatening about it like oh this woman
is threatened by the other woman because
they're the only women hood side her you
know like the times when women have been
pitted against each other in that way it
was just like we're all here to make
something great and to support one
another and have a good time and it was
like amazing it took a bit of convincing
to say like we can put a group of women
on screen in an action film and it will
work Kathy Ann directed the film making
her the second woman to ever direct a DC
film after patty Jenkins Cathy made her
feature directorial debut with dead pigs
the independent movie debuted at the
Sundance Film Festival where it won the
world cinema dramatic Award for ensemble
acting so now you know and now you can
go see birds of prey and theaters
everywhere on February 7th